Ich bin mega nervös.
Es ist schon 17.30 Uhr
und ich bin noch nicht im Stadion.
Ich muss mind. 2 Std. vorher
im Stadion sein.
Ich bin schon den ganzen Tag
kribbelig.
Und frage mich:
"Wie spät ist es? Wie lange noch?"
Es ist nicht so ...
Für meine Krankheit ist es
ein relativ ungünstiges Hobby,
weil ich ja sonst schon Nerven-
stränge verliere wegen der MS -
oder diese geschädigt werden,
so muss ich es sagen.
Und Fussball braucht ja
auch noch ziemlich viel Nerven.
Aber ja ...
Das wird schon.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Luana Montanaro
leidet an einer besonders aggressiven
Form der Multiplen Sklerose.
Über ein Jahr lang
haben wir sie begleitet.
Mit 18 bekam sie
die völlig überraschende Diagnose MS.
Bis dahin war die lebensfrohe Luana
sportlich aktiv und erfolgreich.
Im Tennis war sie
in ihrer Alterskategorie
die Nummer 2 des Nationalkaders.
Und sie spielte Fussball
beim Zweitligisten FC Spiez.
Doch seit neun Jahren ist
Luanas Alltag radikal eingeschränkt.
Wenn ich nicht im Rollstuhl bin,
bin ich im Bett.
Die muss ich nachts anziehen, weil
ich Spastiken in den Händen habe.
Das sieht dann so aus.
Die Ärzte haben Angst,
dass sich meine Hände versteifen,
wenn ich das die ganze Zeit mache -
also das mache ich unbewusst.
Diese Schiene bewirkt,
dass ich die Hand so halte,
dann können sie
nicht zusammenkommen.
Ich muss die Schienen
jeden Abend anziehen
und bin dann einfach so im Bett
und kann die Hände nicht bewegen.
Aber ja, mit der Zeit
gewöhnt man sich daran.
Ich bin eigentlich froh,
dass ich sie habe.
Denn ich will ja nicht, dass sich
meine Hände zu stark versteifen.
Du hast auf dem Nachttischchen
neben den Schienen auch Medikamente.
Wie viele Tabletten
musst du pro Tag nehmen?
44 pro Tag.
Das ist ziemlich viel.
Und ziemlich scheisse.
Hier drin ist das Methadon.
Das bekommen Heroinabhängige
im Methadonprogramm.
Das muss ich nehmen.
Wieso musst du Methadon nehmen?
Wegen der Schmerzen,
der Rückenschmerzen.
Ich habe schon alle Opiate durch,
Fentanyl, Oxynon, alles.
Nichts hat genützt.
Jetzt habe ich Methadon.
Ich habe es ganz am Anfang
mit 19 bekommen,
in einer Dosis,
die Heroinabhängige erhalten.
Das hat mir
ziemlich zu schaffen gemacht,
weil der Körper extrem schnell
abhängig wird von dem Zeug.
Wenn ich heute irgendwohin gehe
und merke, dass ich das Methadon
nicht mitgenommen habe,
ist es wirklich schlimm.
Dann beginne ich zu zittern,
die Schmerzen werden stärker,
ich beginne zu schwitzen,
mir wird übel.
Es ist sehr beängstigend, das
zu merken - es ist nicht der Kopf,
sondern die Methadon-Abhängigkeit
des Körpers.
Aber ich weiss, dass es nichts
anderes gibt, was ich nehmen kann.
Deshalb ist es
Segen und Fluch zugleich.
Die Fachmittelschule musste sie
kurz vor Schluss abbrechen.
Psychologin wollte sie werden,
anderen Menschen helfen.
Sie lebt zusammen
mit ihrer Mutter Karin
und ihrer jüngeren Schwester
Vivienne.
Multiple Sklerose
ist eine chronische Nervenerkrankung,
die das Gehirn
und das Rückenmark betrifft.
Ich habe dir einen hingelegt. Hier.
Bei Luanas aggressiver MS sind
viele Körperfunktionen betroffen:
Erblindung auf dem linken Auge,
Lähmungserscheinungen an den Beinen,
starke Schmerzen,
Blasen- und Darmstörungen.
Ich kann das nicht hineintun.
Moment.
Wie soll ich sie schneiden?
- Ich kann es nicht hineintun.
Ich würde es ohne versuchen.
- Okay.
Nein, das geht nicht.
- Ich nehme es für den Löffel.
Kaum mache ich etwas,
beginne ich zu zittern.
Deshalb muss ich mich
ziemlich konzentrieren.
Auch was die Kraft angeht -
Tomaten sind gerade noch okay.
Guten Appetit.
Wegen der täglichen Kortisontabletten
hat Luana stark an Gewicht zugelegt.
Auf das einzige MS-Medikament,
das wirklich helfen würde,
ist sie allergisch.
Ich hoffe einfach, dass es stoppt,
einfach nicht schlimmer wird.
Es ist alles so rasant gegangen,
gell?- Mhm.
Ich hoffe, dass das zweite Auge,
auf dem sie noch etwas sieht ...
Die Prognose
ist zwar schon schlecht.
Aber dass es wenigstens so bleibt.
Falls sie auf dem zweiten Auge
auch fast nichts mehr sieht ...
Nein,
daran darf ich gar nicht denken.
Luanas geschwächtes Immunsystem
produziert kaum Antikörper.
Und ein MS-Medikament
hat bei ihr zusätzlich
eine Blutkrankheit ausgelöst.
Es ist ein bisschen kompliziert.
Keine Abwehrstoffe, keine B-Zellen.
Die zerstören halt alles und
deshalb muss ich alle zwei Wochen
in diese Therapie kommen,
um Immunglobulin zu bekommen.
Und dazu kommt
die chemoartige Therapie,
die eigentlich hauptsächlich
bei Krebspatienten angewendet wird.
Aber man hat herausgefunden,
dass sie MS-Patienten
auch helfen könnte.
Deshalb bin ich
jede zweite Woche hier.
Hilft es dir?
Die Ärzte sagen so lala.
Ich sage Nein.
Meine Mama sagt auch Nein, weil
es mir ja immer schlechter geht.
Wenn die Ärzte sagen:
"Du musst das machen",
kann ich als kleine Schnecke
ja nicht kommen und sagen:
"Nein, das mache ich nicht."
Hallo, Schätzchen.
Hey.
Bist du müde?
- Ja.
Wie lief es?
- Es geht, wir mussten unterbrechen.
Ihr musstet unterbrechen?
Wurde dir übel?- Ja, mega.
Oh nein.
Mutter Karin arbeitet
nur noch einen halben Tag pro Woche,
um für Luana da zu sein.
Konntest du etwas essen?
- Eine Suppe.
Normalerweise würde Luana
nach dieser Behandlung
komplett erschöpft nach Hause gehen.
Doch heute
spielt ihr geliebter FC Thun.
Hast du genug Energie?
- Ja.
Du musst mir noch helfen,
das T-Shirt anzuziehen.- Welches?
Das Thun-Leibchen.
- Hast du es dabei?- Ja.
Luana und ein Spiel verpassen?
Geht gar nicht.
Der Puls ist auf 380.
Die Schuhe noch,
dann sind wir ready?
Nimmst du die Tasche
oder stösst du Luana?
Ich kann es selbst.
Tschüss, Thorsten.
Tschüss, Luana.
Yes!
Geschafft für heute.
Es ist schon viel zu spät.
Es beginnt doch erst um 20 Uhr.
Ja, aber ich muss mich vorbereiten,
weisst du.
Das kann ich nicht, wenn ich nicht
dort bin. Ich bin viel zu nervös.
Was heisst vorbereiten?
Psychisch darauf hinarbeiten.
93 Min. leiden.
93 Min. Daumen drücken.
93 Min. hoffen.
Ich sage immer,
das ist meine zweite Familie.
Das ist wie ...
Der Mensch braucht Luft zum Atmen,
damit er leben kann.
Der FC Thun ist quasi meine Luft.
Also ohne FC Thun könnte ich
schlichtweg nicht leben.
Was sie für mich machen,
ist grandios.
Es gibt keinen Klub in der Schweiz
und sowieso nicht auf der Welt,
der so ist
wie der FC Thun mir gegenüber.
Sie haben mich im Spital besucht,
schenken mir ihre Trikots,
sie schreiben mir Briefe.
Es ist, wie wenn
eine Singlemutter sagt:
"Mich gibt's nicht ohne mein Kind."
Ich sage immer: "Mich gibt es nicht
ohne den FC Thun."
Genau.
Vor dem Spiel schickt Luana
oft einen Motivationsbrief
an ihren Lieblingsklub.
"Liebe Jungs, meine Blutwerte haben
sich drastisch verschlechtert."
"Das bedeutet nun
jede zweite Woche Chemo."
"Leider trifft's den heutigen Tag."
"Aber trotz 9 Std. Chemo
komme ich natürlich ans Spiel,
will euch unterstützen."
Merci.
"Wenn es manchmal aussichtslos
erscheint, dann rat ich dir,
mein lieber Freund,
gib niemals deine Hoffnung auf,
wie es auch kommt im Lebenslauf."
"Denn wenn du denkst,
es geht nicht mehr,
kommt irgendwo ein Licht daher
und gibt dir Mut,
Kraft und Vertrauen,
dem Schicksal
was aufs Maul zu hauen."
"Zusammenstehen, zusammenhalten,
zusammen siegen."
"Herzlich, euer Maskottchen, Luana."
(Stadionsprecher) Zusammenstehen,
zusammenhalten, zusammen siegen!
Das Stadion ist Luanas Kraftort.
Du hast gesagt, wenn du hier bist,
spürst du deine Schmerzen weniger.
Keine. Nichts.
Wenn sie da sind - nichts.
Mir ist auch weniger übel.
Schon noch übel,
aber ein bisschen weniger.
Es ist ein Derbyspiel 2018,
der FC Thun
gegen die Berner Young Boys.
Thun darf nicht verlieren,
sonst droht der Abstiegskampf.
(Stadionsprecher) 27. Spielminute,
der erste Treffer für YB.
Kommt, Jungs, fighten!
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Komm, komm, komm! Hey!
Der fällt ja einfach um!
Schiess! Nein!
Hopp Thun, hopp Thun, hopp Thun!
Hey, hey!
* Jubelschreie, Applaus *
* Hoffnungsvolle Klaviermusik,
Jubelschreie *
# Ds'Bärneroberland isch schön!
Ja, ds'Oberland, ja, ds'Oberland ...
Unentschieden ― aufatmen.
Ja, jetzt bin ich nudelfertig.
Chemo und Match schauen
ist keine gute Kombination.
Ja! Ja!
Vielen Dank! Gratuliere.
- Lief es gut?
Ja, sehr! Super gespielt.
- Vielen Dank!- Danke.
Von wem ist es?
- Righetti.
Ich bin ein wenig überwältigt,
ich muss es sacken lassen.
Danke, Märki! Danke.
Gut, oder? Du musst nicht weinen,
wir haben nicht verloren.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Drei Monate später.
Luana ist in der REHAB-Klinik Basel,
wo sie immer wieder kämpft,
um ihre noch verbleibenden Kräfte
zu erhalten.
Luana möchte
so lange wie möglich bleiben.
Doch gerade hat ihr das Therapeuten-
team bei der Visite mitgeteilt,
dass sie
nach vier Wochen nach Hause muss.
Ich bin wütend, stinksauer.
Aber es bringt nichts.
Hier gibt es alle Therapien
an einem Ort und jeden Tag.
Das hilft meinem Körper
und meiner Seele sehr.
Ich komme hier einfach
stabiler wieder raus.
Ja, so ist das.
Hier, unter anderen Patienten,
fühlt sie sich verstanden,
hat nicht wie zu Hause das Gefühl,
für Familie und Freunde
eine Belastung zu sein.
Wie geht's?
- Okay.
Hattest du einen langen Tag?
- Nein.
War alles gut bis auf die Visite?
Also, dann komm mal hierhin.
Ja, ich komme.
Also, ohne Punkte,
einfach hin und her.
Damit du weisst,
was auf dich zukommt.
Luanas Therapeut motiviert sie
spielerisch zum Muskelaufbau.
Was leicht aussieht,
erfordert all ihre Kräfte.
Ziehen, ziehen!
Okay, das schreit
nach einem kleinen Match.
Bist du dabei?- Ja.
- Okay. Bist du bereit?
* Sanfte,
hoffnungsvolle Klaviermusik *
Komm! Sehr schön.
Komm, hol ihn, hol ihn!
Okay, eindeutig ein Punkt
für Matthias.
Wieso hast du immer Anspiel?
- Okay!
Daran soll es nicht scheitern.
Komm, schön, rüber!
Wie Nadal.
- Wie Nadal?
* Lachen *
Also.
Allein stehen
ist eine Riesenanstrengung.
Auf drei: eins, zwei und drei.
Und komm, jawohl.
Und komm, steh mal auf. Jawohl.
Was ist das? Nimm die mal runter.
Ich nehme mal die Hände weg.
Das geht einwandfrei.
Und halten, noch einmal hinsetzen,
Pause. Super!
Und Pause.
Sehr gut!
Das wäre dein Ziel, oder?
Stehend die Zähne zu putzen?
Jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr üben.
- Was meinst du?
Ich kann es nicht mehr üben.
- Wieso nicht?
Weil ich am Mittwoch nach Hause
muss.- Ah, meine Schuld.- Ja.
Doch, das kannst du üben.
Die Therapie geht weiter.
Nein, es ist jetzt später.
- Später.
Also, mach's gut, sehr toll.
- Bis später.
Ja, um 13 Uhr?
- Ja.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Wasser ist Magie für Luana:
Hier verwandelt sich
die Unerträglichkeit des Schicksals
kurz in eine Schwerelosigkeit
des Seins.
Das REHAB-Team hat entschieden,
dass Luana bereits nach vier Wochen
die gesteckten Therapieziele
erreicht hat.
Wir haben gemerkt:
Mit einem Ball geht einiges besser.
Sie vergisst,
was sie eigentlich nicht kann.
Und sie merkt am Schluss,
was sie eigentlich leisten konnte.
Das ist das Schöne -
und wir erwarten,
dass sie zu Hause genauso viel
Freude an einem Schwimmbad hat
oder mal was versucht,
wie hier bei uns im REHAB.
Vier Monate später.
Luana hat einen schlimmen Rückfall
und ist auf einem Tiefpunkt.
Am Morgen aufzustehen
ist für mich ziemlich sinnlos.
Ich stehe jetzt auf, weil ich
einen Hund habe, weil sie raus muss.
Ich mache es für den Hund.
Weil ich will, dass es ihr gut geht.
Aber es ist einfach
brutal anstrengend,
jeden Tag aufzustehen im Wissen,
dass es jeden Tag
ein bisschen schlechter geht.
Und es ist anstrengend,
für viele Menschen so rüberzukommen,
als wäre ich eine grosse Kämpferin.
Aber zu Hause, wenn ich
alleine in meinem Zimmer bin,
bin ich am Weinen,
weil ich es fast nicht mehr aushalte
wegen der Schmerzen und der Spastik.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich
nie einen Freund haben werde.
Wer will schon jemanden
im Rollstuhl?
Und eine Miss Schweiz
bin ich auch nicht gerade.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwie habe ich
die Hoffnung aufgegeben,
dass ich mal jemanden
an meiner Seite haben werde.
Ich habe zwar meine Familie,
meine Freunde, den FC Thun.
Aber das sind so kleine Momente,
die flackern manchmal auf,
5 Min., 10 Min., vielleicht 20 Min.,
und dann ist es wieder schwarz.
Du hast dich bei Exit angemeldet.
Warum?
Weil ich sehr oft
sehr starke Suizidgedanken habe.
Und dort, irgendwie ...
Das klingt blöd, aber irgendwie
stirbst du so in Würde.
Bettlägerig und blind zu werden,
nicht mehr sprechen zu können,
ist Luanas grösste Angst.
Luana ist wieder im REHAB.
Dieses Mal darf sie
neun Wochen bleiben.
Nach ihrem Tief hat sie
von einer Stammzelltherapie gehört
und möchte unbedingt ins Programm
aufgenommen werden.
Wieder droht dem FC Thun der Abstieg.
Aber auch in schlechten Klub-Zeiten
schöpft Luana
von ihren Kickern Kraft.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich den Ball spiele
und einen Schritt gehe,
sage ich im Kopf
einen Spielernamen des FC Thun auf.
Also, so beim Spielen:
"Chris Kablan",
wieder spielen,
"Dennis Hediger", usw.
Sehr schön.
Für die Stammzellentransplantation
gibt es drei Bedingungen,
damit ich evtl. zugelassen werde.
Eine davon ist, 50 m zu gehen.
Das ist es, was mich
eigentlich am meisten anspornt.
Weil es das Einzige ist,
was mir noch helfen kann,
weil es immer schlechter wird.
Die zweite Bedingung ist,
etwas abzunehmen.
Ich habe 7 kg abgenommen.
Das ist noch nicht viel,
aber ich probiere es immer mehr.
Und die dritte Bedingung, die kann
ich leider nicht beeinflussen,
ist die Bluterkrankung.
Und das hat halt am meisten Gewicht,
weil es gefährlicher ist,
die Stammzellen zu machen
mit dieser Bluterkrankung,
weil ich sonst ja
schon keine Immunglobulin habe,
dann noch die Chemo,
die zusätzlich kommen würde.
Das Risiko ist einfach
noch einmal viel höher,
und weil es eine Studie ist,
wollen sie natürlich das Risiko,
dass etwas passiert,
so klein wie möglich halten,
und deshalb bin ich
nicht so ein geeigneter Fall,
wegen dieser Bluterkrankung.
Aber für mich ist es eigentlich
die letzte Möglichkeit,
weil alles andere, das wir probiert
haben, nicht angeschlagen hat.
Siebenmal umfallen,
achtmal aufstehen.
Das ist Luanas Fussball-
und Lebensmotto.
Ah!
- Oh ...
Ja!
* Sie atmet schwer. *
Komm, weiter.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Lachen *
Okay, nicht schlecht. Aufstehen!
Das ist schon fast ... Wie steht's?
Ich weiss es gar nicht.
- Hands, Penalty!- Also.
Wart du nur!
* Lachen *
Wow!
Auffällig war: Als sie ohne den Ball
ging, als wir zum Stuhl gingen,
hat man ganz deutlich gemerkt,
dass ihr Fokus auf ihrer Ataxie
und der Spastik lag, was nicht geht.
Da kamen wahrscheinlich
auch die Schmerzen wieder.
Und beim Match konnte ich
Bodychecks geben, sie fiel zu Boden,
stand wieder auf - sie war fröhlich,
wie es sein sollte,
ohne darüber nachzudenken,
dass sie ihre Krankheit hat.
Ich kann diese 50 m
halt nur am Ball gehen.
Aber ja.
Das Prinzip Hoffnung ist halt
schon sehr in mir verankert.
Keine Ahnung,
wenn du nur noch eine Hoffnung hast,
krallst du dich halt daran fest und
versuchst, noch das Beste zu geben.
Kannst du noch?
- Ja.
Willst du noch einmal?
Okay.
* Sanfte,
hoffnungsvolle Klaviermusik *
War der drin?
- Der war drin!
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Laura Thomann - 2020